let's get into it rodney harris is going
to join us later in the program with
some discussion about best safeties in
the nfl and also get his thoughts on the
biggest topic right now in the national
football league just two days ago there
was one player who had exercised the
privilege to opt out of the 2020 season
as a concession to the pandemic and the
concerns that players have the health
issues they may have the family issues
they may have and it was one guy and
there were people around the league who
were speculating and estimating as of
monday that the ultimate total of
players who opt out would be in the
single digits well
as of right now
there's more than 25
who have opted out chris and it's been
one after another after another after
another and a bunch of patriots are out
devon functions is out that i think is
one of the biggest names even though he
hasn't played for the packers yet yeah
was one of the reasons why they didn't
draft us here yeah how's that draft
going now that draft doesn't seem as
good now oh no oh gosh now we don't
we're
we're minus one more receiver but you're
right that one even though he hasn't
played you're right it does jump out you
know along with a bunch of others i mean
certainly i mean i think the one thing
we're seeing we see a little bit of a
trend of big guys right that's one thing
that jumps out to me defensive tackles
don't know what their issues are or
whatever but obviously there's a concern
there and we've heard the issues are
they're not they're big guys i know
right bmi bmi chris in excess of 30 body
mass index excess of 30 is one of the
risk factors for dying from this right
right the bigger you are the the greater
the chance of a
serious
outcome very worst case scenario so
that's the motivation for a lot of these
guys michael pierce for example the
vikings defensive lineman the run
stuffer who replaces linval joseph he
opts out he's got health issues he's a
big man and now the vikings have to look
elsewhere i mean this is something that
potentially every team is going to have
to deal with and a team like the
patriots gonna have to deal with for a
bunch of different guys no i know you
know i mean yeah you think about the
vikings they lose a player you replace
them and now you go whoa we're gonna be
we not only are we not replacing
linville joseph but the guy we brought
in to replace him he can't play now
we're really thin at that position so
yeah michael pierce eddie goldman for
the chicago bears one of the best nose
tackles in all of football that's a huge
blow to their team starlot de lele with
buffalo you know the cold front defense
there he's going to be a big part of
that not there and then of course new
england like you're saying and you know
some shocking names out of new england
of course marcus cannon we know he has
the health issues that's that hurts but
the ones that really jump out
of course are dante hightower and
patrick chung you know brandon bolden a
special teams extraordinaire you know
one of those guys belichick loves
because he's a swiss army knife he can
play receiver running back special teams
do it all but man when i think about
hightower and chung not a part of that
defense this year in a year where hey it
is cam newton there's gonna feel it be a
few bumps in the road on the offensive
side of the ball there was bumps in the
road last year but chung hightower you
know we've seen videos and heard
belichick talk about you know they can
come up with adjustments and call
defenses and make adjustments that might
not have been in that weekly game plan
because maybe they didn't expect the
offense to do something but they know
because years and years in the system
and hearing bill talk and and everybody
else that they knew what what proper
adjustments should be made so i look at
that as being some of the the two
shocking ones to me
also because i know how much those two
love football and uh that must have you
know been a very tough decision but
that's a tough loss for the patriots who
are going to have to play through their
defense i would think early in the year
if we do play football
and chris for the most part i have not
noticed any blowback for the players who
are making this gut-wrenching decision
to sit out all of 2020 and remember once
it's official it's irrevocable and i'm
glad to see that look this is an
intensely personal decision we respect
and support the ability of a player to
walk away from the sport that he loves
to walk away from the money that goes
along with it to enter a year of
uncertainty where you have to sit back
remember you've told me before how it
felt to have to watch football the first
year that you weren't part of football
and how hard that is yeah you're
watching the train rolling away from you
with no guarantee
you're going to be able to catch up to
the train next year because
we know how this goes right if dante
hightower's replacement
is just good enough where dollar for
dollar it makes more sense to keep him
instead of dante hightower next year
bill belichick's not gonna pay dante
hightower eight million dollars next
year same thing for patrick chung they
find somebody else who can come in and
get it done and that's a guy who's and
and here's the here's where it gets
a little bit dicey
because on one hand these teams need to
respect the decisions made by the
players to opt out
on the other hand chris you know it
and i know it there's going to be a
temptation
for the coaches to say
for the guys who are there you chose to
be here this year yeah no doubt no doubt
you chose to go to battle with your
teammates and that
consciously or not
is going to be a feather in those guys
caps next year it shouldn't be yeah to
the detriment of the guys who opted out
but you know how it works it will be no
i it will be you know and you know
everything you've said so far there and
that last point it's all true you know
dante hightower patrick chung they're
getting to that point of their careers
too where you know hightower's in year
nine
okay yeah
you know these are two positions that we
know the patriots collect you know so
many players linebackers so many
versatile players that way safety they
got a a whole cabinet full of them too
to match up against every type of guy
and football but you know yeah they're
they're at risking at the point where oh
they might be you're right never back in
the league and we'll see where it goes
and some of the other guys unless
they're superstars
yeah they're gonna
unless they have i think a huge health
concern
they're not gonna be looked at in a
positive manner like people are gonna
respect it but they're gonna be like ah
i mean come on he didn't play well i
mean so i think there is gonna be some
of that talk with for the coaches and
the players there's no doubt about that
you know it's a tough one something just
to be clear yeah something that's never
articulated publicly right exactly right
it kind of just you know we we
all it's the kind of thing where like
the group of five guys playing xbox
right who are really close friends on
the team or whatever they're you're
sitting around having a beer and they
know okay i can't say this to the whole
team but these are my best friends on
the team can you believe he's not here
and playing with us this year i can't
believe he did that yes some of that is
going to go on for sure
we all experience that we all
potentially engage in that from time to
time let's be realistic there's the
thing will say to someone
because we don't want to have the
awkward interaction we know that being
candid and
and blunt is not the best way to go and
then when there's an opportunity to talk
to somebody else behind the curtain you
say what you really think and that may
happen here there may be that disconnect
of oh we we really respect him he's
doing the right thing for himself and
his friend can you believe can you right
can you okay we're here
where's he yeah right i'd love to be
sitting home all year you know that kind
of stuff that's human nature that's
going to be part of this equation john
schneider the seahawks gm appeared
yesterday on the peter king podcast and
schneider was asked if he thought
players were worried about that stigma
of letting the team down if they opted
out here's what schneider had to say
during the summer through all these
negotiations and everything i don't
think that
you know the football fans across the
country probably don't understand how
many
uh
calls you know the union's been on with
their players in the league and the
union and going back and forth so i
think there's been enough discussion
where you know players
are going to respect each other's
feelings about
opting out or or going for it and
playing and you're trying to
try to trying to respect each other with
all the rules that we have set in place
now with with uh you know all this all
this all these code protocols because i
just think it's uh
obviously we need to do the best job we
possibly can and and you know learn from
major league baseball and and the nhl
and
and um you know the nba you know we're
i've been in contact with the nba teams
nhl teams we have other people that have
you know uh major league baseball
contacts so we're doing whatever we can
to take the correct precautions and i
don't think players are going to
have any animosity towards each other
apples to apples is baseball because the
nba has a bubble the nhl has a bubble
mls has a bubble the nfl can't as a
practical matter at this point have a
bubble you could make the argument it
was never practical and never would have
been practical for the nfl to have a
true bubble where everyone was isolated
in one location so that's what makes
baseball more relevant and we see what's
going on in baseball this week although
the good news for baseball it looks like
the marlins outbreak didn't spread to
the phillies even though they played
them right three days to start the
season but they're not pressed on top of
each other they're not right across from
each other they're not spitting and
sweating and breathing and bleeding on
each other like football players do
that's the grand experiment when
football starts but you know chris look
the bottom line is as we said
they're just going to have to deal with
it even if they don't like it and it's
it occurred to me earlier when we showed
the list of the guys who have opted out
i think from a coaching and front office
standpoint you have to treat each of the
guys who opt out like they had a torn
acl the first day of practice it's the
same thing and it doesn't happen with
this frequency you don't have 25 torn
acls the first day of camp but that's
essentially what it is we have a guy
who we know he's gone for the year
and we know it at the start of camp and
we can make a plan and we have to make a
plan let's go yeah and coaches have all
had to do that it's just this year
they're going to have to do it
potentially more than ever before yeah
they're going to have to be ready for
everything and you know and and not only
just one two three guys you're right a
whole position group whatever it may be
i mean yeah uh hey this is this is weird
times i certainly respect you know the
players and what they got to do i don't
you know to me like i want to ask you
personally
like i could never i know i could never
do that i couldn't i wouldn't sit out
football this year unless i knew i had a
really
you know
big time health issue i understand you
know the marcus cannons and you know the
body mass index certainly a real thing
i'm just saying me as chris sims if i
was back in the nfl right now as a
quarterback the thing that would scare
me more than anything is something you
said at the start of the show
i'd be more scared of sitting on my
couch on sunday and going damn football
happened they're playing it's a full
year not that many guys are getting sick
and it's week eight and i'm sitting here
on my butt on the couch and that would
be like a nightmare for me
at least you know and i know everybody's
different but i think there's a lot of
guys in football that look at it the
same way where they just go man we're
playing football i'm gonna be there and
i don't know if there's much that could
stop me other than you know
you know really the fact of just yes
death in itself and i had a really
serious condition to go along with it
but uh i respect it it's tough and yeah
teams are gonna have to deal with this
and mike the other thing i just think of
is this why like
hey i mean
everybody better be ready this year in
the nfl i mean you could be the 25th
best team in football and there could be
a few outbreaks with a few teams and
damn you're back in you know the playoff
contention or whatever it may be and
it's gonna make you know i think the
competitive balance even more
competitive this year maybe if we
continue to have little outbreaks here
and there and here and there and of
course guys not playing altogether
well there won't be competitive balance
because they aren't going to worry about
that but the reality is you got 16 teams
seven get in nine don't the chances of
being one of the seven are dramatically
increased because you're right you could
be three games back with four games to
play from that last playoff spot and all
of a sudden the team that's holding that
last playoff spot loses 20 of its
regulars right and they fall apart you
know it's kind of like the dynamic of
the replacement three-week window in
1987 but it can pop up at any time for
any team
and a team that has everything moving in
the right direction can have it all fall
apart in december and miss the playoffs
all together or you could roll into the
postseason 14-2 number one seed uh oh
here's the outbreak happy new year here
it goes and you have nobody that well
not you know what i'm saying you have an
outbreak and you have key players gone
right for the division around game and
you get knocked out of the postseason i
think it adds to the drama in the end
right that's what i meant by it yeah
yeah right chris
i i wanna i wanna respond to something
you said about that that notion of
sitting on the couch all year and seeing
football go on without you i wonder how
many of the guys who are opting out
other than the ones who have real
medical issues serious medical issues
the high risk opt outs yep
are they hedging their bets here are
they looking at this saying right
i don't think this is going to work
and i'd rather not be part of it if it's
not going to work right my prediction is
they're not going to get a full season
in my prediction is they're going to
pull the plug on this thing some point
mid to late september or october why do
i want to be there for training camp why
do i want to take these risks i wondered
at the end of it at the end of the day
right it's just not going to happen or
it's not going to be
a full season it's going to be a
complete season where every team plays
four regular season games whatever the
case may be there's too much chaos
there's too much uncertainty i don't
want to be in a situation where we play
a game one week and then have three
weeks until our next game and never
quite know when we're going to play or
where we're going to play or who we're
going to be playing against or who's
going to be lining up next to me you
know this reminds me of something rodney
harrison told me
four or five weeks ago during our hiatus
we had him on the pftpn podcast he said
you got enough to worry about as a
professional football player you got
your job to do you got to process the
playbook you got to know your role you
got to know how you interact with
everyone else you're constantly thinking
about that
and now on top of it you're worried
about the guy next to you you're worried
about where are you going to get covered
you're worried about are you going to
take it home to your family you're
worried about all this other stuff
that you ordinarily don't have to worry
about i think for some of these guys it
may just be you look at it and the
problem is you got to make the decision
now yeah so you're projecting you're
guessing you're speculating you're
estimating but i think some of these
guys are saying
i got a bad feeling about this
so i'm just i'm out and and if i'm wrong
i'm wrong but you know what i may be
right i i mean i crossed my mind
certainly yeah they are they hedging or
they calling the nfl's bluff yeah they
don't know what's gonna happen and they
you know gonna get
you know uh they figure they're guys
that figured maybe i'm not gonna make a
team this year who knows i'll just
collect some money they're not going to
really ask me for the money back next
year uh i i mean yeah i don't know all
those things have crossed my mind
certainly but that's a dangerous game to
play as we know because there's some
guys here on this list where i want to
go
oh man you know you're not you're not
guaranteed to ever play football again
you know it's going to be tough i mean
devin functions would be a guy that i
would look at and go well you didn't
play last year you know
it didn't end great in carolina two
years ago and now you don't play again
this year you know teams aren't going to
be lining up to sign devin functions
next year and and i'm and again i'm not
trying to get in his personal life
totally respect his decision i'm just
using him as an example of just hey
being around football all my life this
is how coaches think man he hasn't
played football in two years i don't
want him on my team oh he hasn't played
football in two years i don't know have
you seen it is there any tape of them in
the last two years nope okay then i
don't care about them you know that's
what some of these guys are certainly
going to have to worry about they're
rolling the dice on that aspect of it
let alone the other part what we talked
about where yeah i think privately
you'll have coaches and players who'll
be a little bit pissed that that guy
wasn't in the trenches with him if we do
have the season and everything like that
so
a lot of factors here and
again i don't want to sound
disrespectful to anybody who's sitting
down no you're not you're not no look
here's the reality we see this every
year when a guy gets injured and is gone
for the year it's out of sight out of
mind and someone else steps in you know
all the hand-wringing about whether or
not the undrafted free agents are gonna
have a fair shake to make the roster at
the end of the day there's 53 guys per
team yeah at the end of it like you know
the idea well adam thielen never would
have made it onto the vikings well you
know what we would have never noticed we
would have known who adam thielen is
that's how it works you have the guys
who make the team the guys who are in
the starting jobs those are the ones who
generate the statistics those are the
ones that you get on your fantasy team
those are the ones we see highlights of
and there's always going to be those
guys and if you're not part of that it
just keeps going without you right we
saw it with ben roethlisberger last year
we saw it with cam newton last year
that's the way it works so for all these
guys who are choosing to opt out the
train keeps rolling and you've got to
find a way to scramble back onto it next
year for some guys it'll be
easy for some guys it won't be easy and
it may be over and this year that you
choose to take off a year from now
assuming the pandemic's gone by then and
let's hope that it's gone by then we
don't know what the mindset of the coach
is to be it very well could be that
these coaches have greater loyalty to
the guys who chose to be there than the
guys who chose to not be there even
though everyone is supporting and
respecting the decisions of the guys to
not be there yeah no i think that that's
exactly right you're right i mean i
think the only the ones with the the
real real health concerns like a marcus
cannon who has who's had cancer right i
don't think there will be any personal
you know mean thoughts towards those
situations but like like we've talked
about everything else i think it's gonna
be a little question certainly and mike
here's something else that just because
you brought up baseball and i keep
coming back to this and and hear me out
here and you think i know i'm crazy but
just let me know if you think this is
totally like crazy
all right we saw this weekend baseball's
going right but we've had four teams who
can't play because they've had an
outbreak right they're going to figure
out how to make these games up it's
baseball it's not that hard to do uh and
so yes that's great but i still come
back to what if we've played six weeks
in the nfl
and you have four or five teams in a
given week all of a sudden that come out
and they can't play a game in week seven
right it's everybody's six games in it's
week seven and now we have four or five
teams that can't play
right and then the next week after that
it's two or three teams you know how are
they gonna do that you know and this is
where my mind's going and this is where
i want you to think i'm crazy
should we just count those as forfeits
like hey you had an outbreak on your
team it's a forfeit you lost i'm sorry
does that add incentive to make players
not want to be crazy off the field or do
anything like that i'm just throwing
this out there do you i see you're
shaking your head no
i i because peter king and i have talked
about this and he's written about it in
football morning in america i think it's
more likely that games would be
postponed that they're not going to
find a team at fault hey you can't field
a team so you forfeit it's not like the
little league team that only shows up
with seven kids right this is through no
fault of your own in the middle of a
pandemic we can't stage the game because
we're deeming you not to have enough
healthy players to play and to protect
the players who are on the field so
we're going to try to play this game
week 18 or week 19. that seems to be
which way the wind is blowing with the
commissioner having wide latitude to
decide when a game gets postponed when
it doesn't that's what concerns me
because that wide latitude can easily be
misused or at least used in a way that
causes reasonable minds to differ and
you can have patriots fans saying here
he is screwing us again right making us
play without our starting yeah offensive
line but the chiefs get to to postpone
their game yeah because we have to
protect patrick mahomes i could see
those kinds of issues come up i don't
think the nfl cares the objective is to
get the games in and there will be i
think a trigger that gets games
postponed without a forfeit without a
cancellation but if they can't get the
games in that's what i that's where i
just go like if there's too many and
then they never
have one team that plays 12 games and
another team that plays nine games how
are we going to figure that out and we
determine playoff position based on
win-loss percentage period now you know
as long as it's within one two or three
games it's okay but if one team plays
four and another team plays 16 then
we're getting ridiculous but that's not
that's not going to happen one last
point to keep in mind yeah the opt out
deadline has widely been reported as
monday august 3rd the truth is this
the clock on the opt out officially runs
seven days from the signing of the side
agreement that amends the collective
bargaining agreement
that hasn't been signed yet so
right now this moment the earliest that
the opt-out window will close is next
wednesday august 5. so guys have more
time
to go to the facility
see how it feels
monitor the situations see what's
happening in baseball or other sports
before they make that final decision i
think they should have all the way up
until week one frankly to make that
final decision or maybe even after the
first regular season game how does it
feel to go on the road how does it feel
to play in a game during a pandemic the
nfl wants that door closed sooner than
later but chris the reality is this the
door's not closing
until at the earliest next wednesday so
guys have two more days than we thought
they were going to have if they don't
get this side agreement signed today
they're going to have three more days
than we thought and every hour counts
when you're talking about making
this decision that you cannot take back
there is no mulligan there is no i
didn't take my hand off the checker once
you do it you're done for the year
period chris period yeah that's what's
amazing that's why i'm amazed so many
guys have done it now right why do it
right now
other than you just don't want to show
up like i only want to go into the
facility i'm doing it now i can
understand that over the course of the
next week though let's see if you're
thinking about it right now and you're
already reported wait until the absolute
last minute wait you'll get all the
information you can
and and make that decision at the last
possible moment uh because once you make
it you're done yeah no totally agree
that's at least what i would do wait you
know let's see let's see how it plays
out let me gather all the information
you can get and go from there um but hey
there's more time for some of these guys
to figure it out we'll see where it goes
all right and in a time of anything but
normalcy for the nfl
we have something that is very normal
and very usual but very eye-opening the
chain threatening to break the nfl's
back the chargers break the bank for
joey bosom we'll break down a
record-setting deal for a defensive
player all time when pfc live continues
right after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports